first let me start by saying great great
work one of the things I think that is
there's so much technically in this
movie to unpack between the high frame
rate the what you guys did with Will
Smith's performance and you guys have
worked on a number of movies was this
like the number one challenge that
you've ever had it was it was pretty
hard yeah doing it like their whole
reason that since I started in Visual
Effects 25 years ago we've looked into
trying to make digital people and we are
just all in hate Nate Lee experts at the
nuance that you know if anything is even
slightly wrong we look at and say this
this something creepy about it and this
is not real so we had to do pull that
off and it's at 120 there is no hiding
it is just in your face and you see
every single detail and that all has to
work we call like a symphony of of
different aspects that have to be
alright for you to believe that what
you're seeing is a real person and it's
really Will Smith this was challenging
what we wrote this went down what were
the surprises like challenges that you
weren't that you hadn't foreseen and
prep that hit you on set or in post so
one of the things that going into the
film right the beginning before before
even perhaps starts when you have the
conversation and can you do a digital
human we have this preconceived yeah you
think about it for a while and you make
up this road map in your head of what's
gonna happen over time
and you have sort of the challenges that
you think you're gonna be faced with we
were blown away by the fact that we were
wrong right you know but how wrong we
were
we thought that creating and digital
human would be the hardest challenge
that making something believable as a
breathing living organic creature in
frame was going to be the biggest single
thing that we'd have to overcome we you
know treated with a we as far as
performance and likeness to will we knew
this would be hard but we we you know
that was kind of our wheelhouse we've
done that before you know so we felt
relatively confident and that once we
started going forward and getting into
the shots we rapidly reached a point
where we had a
lievable breathing human being on frame
when I say rapidly I mean six months
seven months later but what surprised us
was the razor's edge and I keep using
that term a lot I'm sorry but the
razor's edge of if you get even just one
micron wrong it falls off of being
wolvesmouth
right and performance is not you know
likeness isn't just a single frame of
Will Smith looking like Will Smith every
single pose the way he blinks the way he
smiles the way he travels his lips up
into a smile if any part of that travel
is ever so slightly wrong the human
brain which is totally attuned to
recognize that a person's face throws a
flag and says I still believe it being a
living thing but just don't know if
that's will and when some of the early
comments we received were it looks I
totally believe that it's a human that
I've filmed on camera it just looks like
twirls cousin one of the things we
didn't expect we're working on a bunch
of shots and he we dialed it all in and
we're looking at it and said yes
something's just not will enough and we
started to realize that what we're used
to the canonical will he had a bon
vivants he had a this light-hearted
character in in all the films and we're
looking at these shots and juniors not
juniors are very brooding character and
until we we found a couple scenes from
bad boys and that where he was scowling
and we put it up next to our character
and realized that we actually had nailed
it exactly we just weren't used to
seeing Will Smith act this way so it's
kind of fun that we could now see Will
Smith at 23 playing a different role
that were used to I'm curious the scenes
in this in the day they're scenes in
this at night were you always secretly
hoping that you were like the movie we
can take place more at night or did it
matter no I don't think so I think the
the you know it's it comes down to the
getting the the science of what lights
doing to the face right it should
respond properly in all different
lighting environments your even though
we say night night doesn't really hide
stuff movie night is never really that
dark and you're seeing a lot of detail
even in the dark shot salutely way to
think of it is that when you do a night
scene you don't tell your actor they can
take a break on
performance right you know he still has
to give a great performance even when
the cameras are you know rolling on a
dark scene so the same occurs with the
CG we assumed that every shot was the
worst-case scenario every shot had to be
dealt with as if it was the most damning
shot that we had to do in fact one of
the the shot that the first shot that I
saw that they had delivered that really
looked perfect but I didn't see a single
flaw was a day scene when he's in the
Gemini Training Center in there they're
looking over at soldiers like ice cream
with the ice cream there he's on
indirect light and and just completely
bought it so it's a it is a testament
that what a that the deep dive to study
how you know with digital humans the
technology had gotten to a point where
the difference between looking like
reality and looking like just a decent
CGI thing was almost subconscious and to
get the rest away there was studying
just the most tiny nuances of how light
bounces through the skin how the
different layers of enamel you have on
your teeth and how light behaves because
even as artists we couldn't point to it
and say look at that that's wrong it's
we needed the computer to do the right
thing just like a DP when he's filming
someone doesn't know exactly what the
lights doing in their face they they
lights up that lines up the scene with
the proper lighting to make it look
pretty and then nature does its thing
we're at that point where the computers
have to do that for us as well well one
of the things is that in my looking at
it from the outside you guys did a ton
of R&D to bring this thing to life and I
would imagine that this movie
essentially paid for this ability in the
future to now take this technology and
amplify it what is there something that
you sort of are looking forward to to be
able to add to this technology for the
future like with whether it be the
software doing more of the work so the
human doesn't have to move certain
switches or could you sort of talk about
that
one of the main things I mean you know
moving forward what would be great to do
is to have a better understanding of how
the face works and what I mean by that
is how muscles interact with fashio
interact with skin and you know moves
your face around a lot of effort is
spent trying to get every pose of the
face exactly right
and it's not just as small as a small
it's a
is that a specific person's version of a
smile here's like I said you can be off
in the most subtle of ways and it's not
like the corner has to be up here the
corner to be just a half a millimeter
too deep and all of a sudden it looks
wrong so having a better understanding
of all that kind of stuff and being able
to arrive at that results faster would
mean that we could do this more readily
on more occasions one of the challenges
too will be you know we had the
advantage of having Will Smith play Will
Smith and you know there's no better
imitator of Will Smith than himself so
the the movement and the performance
that we were getting fit perfectly for
the model that we were using if you were
to do something else like have a
different actor drive something that
that has another unique set of
challenges of how to make the same issue
that's even the best imitators you know
doing an impersonation there that's
great but you can still tell a slight
difference if we're trying to close that
gap to you know perfection that's that's
something we have to figure out
completely I already have to go I mean
it sincerely your work is incredible
have a fantastic day
thank you